18 meses de prisión preventiva para
Pedro Castillo previo a que expire este
miércoles el arresto preliminar al ex
mandatorio peruano la solicitud de la
fiscalía que deberá resolverse en 48
horas podría exacerbar las protestas que
resuenan en todo el país desde
el día
[Música]
y ahora lo trajeron a secuestrarlo acá y
por eso el pueblo está luchando pero el
castillo fue detenido Poco después de
ser destituido por los legisladores
cuando trato de disolver El Congreso
antes de una votación para definir su
salida del poder por sospechas de
corrupción y está siendo investigado por
cargos de rebelión y conspiración los
manifestantes exigen su Liberación la
dimisión de su sucesora Dina boluarte y
la celebración de elecciones generales
anticipadas un tema sobre lo cual la
nueva presidenta de Perú Se comprometió
a trabajar con el congreso
he dicho que vamos a adelantar las
elecciones si bien es cierto conforme el
cronograma que no lo manejo Yo lo maneja
el congreso
se dijo que hasta el 2024 pero igual ya
estoy sacando una cita con la comisión
de Constitución para que con ellos
podamos acortar los plazos ante la
violencia entre manifestantes y las
fuerzas de seguridad Dina boluarte sigue
llamando a la calma en el país pero las
protestas muestran pocos signos de ceder
según la policía las carreteras
nacionales en al menos 14 regiones del
país han sido bloqueadas